>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
It is my great pleasure
to welcome Brazilian author, Noemi
Jaffe, to the library of Congress.
We just had a session recording for
the Archives of Hispanic Literature
on tape, and it was amazing.
So please look forward to
listening to her read from her work.
Noemi Jaffe taught
Brazilian literature full-time
for over 20 years, and then
one day decided I'm going
to be a full-time writer, which
is what she does currently,
besides teaching creative
writing in Brazil, as well.
She's a frequent contributor
to the Cultural Supplement
of the [Portuguese name] and
also writes a monthly column
for the newspaper [Portuguese name]
and for the magazine,
Harper's Bazaar.
She's the author of 10 titles,
starting with her book of poetry,
which was also her first
book published, right?
[Portuguese name], All the
Little Things, published in 2005.
In 2016, she received
the Brazil Literary Prize
for her novel [Portuguese
name] The Orchids.
Today, she will be
reading and talking
about her recently translated novel
[Portuguese name] What are the Blind
Men Dreaming?
Which was a finalist for the prize
[Portuguese name] Literary Prize
in Brazil.
She is joined by Vivaldo dos Santos,
who is an associate professor
of Portuguese at Georgetown
University,
where he's also the director
of the Portuguese program.
Vivaldo is the author
of a book on the poetry
of Carlos [Portuguese name],
among many other titles
on Brazilian literature and culture.
Welcome Noemi and Vivaldo.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
[Portuguese word].
First of all, I'd like to
thank the Library of Congress
and especially the Hispanic
division and the publishers
for organizing this event,
and also Noemi for being here,
and I'd like to, first of all just
to congratulate her on her book.
It's such a beautiful book.
Very touching, and I just love her
book, and it make me think a lot
about -- I always think
about my mother.
I actually brought Noemi a poem
that I wrote about my mother.
She's 99 years old,
and she had 17 kids.
Lots of stories.
This is just, you know,
for me to let her know
that when I read your book,
I was very touched by it
and it did me think about, you
know, memories and also in growing
up in family, the struggle,
different kind of struggles,
but I think the life story
of your mother, your family,
it's an example, very touching.
And I think the Jewish condition
is something that anybody
that has had suffered or
going through any diasporic,
the African-Americans,
when the Jewish minorities.
I think it's a very
important thing in life
to reflect of our human conditions.
And I would just start,
I have several questions.
I try not to be too professor and
have the audience ask questions.
So I will just start with a
question about the title of the book
and What are The Blind Men Dreaming?
And to think about the title of
the book and also asking Noemi,
what way are you dreaming or made
you dream about writing your book?
>> Noemi Jaffe: Okay
well first of all,
I'd also like to think the Library
of Congress for inviting me,
Talia and Vivaldo, and I'd also like
to say how excited I am to be here.
It's a dream of mine
to come to the library,
imagine even talking in the library.
So I'm very excited.
And good. Well, to
answer your question,
it's a question everybody
wants to know, right?
Because the title is pretty strange.
Well, my mother is a
very curious person.
She's always wondering about
phenomenon, natural phenomenon,
about cosmic phenomenons,
and she usually calls me
or asks me questions about natural
things like why is the world round?
And why do dogs bark?
And while I was writing the book,
she called me one day and asked me,
"Noemi, what are the
blind men dreaming?"
And the question was so --
it came just out of the blue,
it was so poetic, that I
didn't know how to answer her,
but I immediately said,
mom, that's the title
of the book, and she agreed with me.
She was wondering what
blind men dream of,
because his blind men don't see,
she was thinking how do they dream
if they don't see, right?
But she has this problem
in her Brazilian grammar.
She hasn't learned Brazilian
grammar very well, and so instead
of asking what do blind
men dream of, she asked,
"What are the blind men dreaming?"
And I like this mistake, quotes,
because it somehow talks a lot
about herself, the way she lives.
She lives in the present
continuously.
That's her decision.
That in order to survive
what she went through,
because she is a survivor
from Auschwitz,
she decided to forget
everything that happened to her.
So she's always living
in the present tense,
and the present continues
to be more specific.
So in the first place, I
thought it was very compatible,
very convenient.
The present continuous was
the best tense for her.
So what are the blind men dreaming?
And also, the content of the
question was also perfect,
because it talks about her
imagination, about her curiosity,
and also, it describes the
blindness, both of the people
who are inside the camp, and who
are forbidden to dream, right?
Because when you're suffering
as people do inside a concentration
camp, how can you dream of anything?
And also because they didn't know
what was happening outside the camp,
what was happening the world, right?
And also, because the
people outside the camp,
both the ones who did know
what was going on inside it,
but didn't do anything, right?
Because people who work
in the city of Auschwitz,
they were feeling the smell
of burning flesh all day long,
and they didn't do anything.
Not even go to the
border of the camp to see
if people needed a
piece of bread, nothing.
And also, the people who
didn't know what was happening,
because Germany tried to
disguise it is much as they could.
And I think the third reason is
because I think people
are still blind
to what's happening
in the world, right?
Because there are happening things
that are similar to what happened
in Auschwitz, and we're
still blind to it.
We're not doing much.
And so that's the reason
for the title of the book.
And there are other reasons.
People always come up
with different reasons.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: And thank
you, that was following up.
I was thinking about also
the meaning of dreams and,
you know, how one dreams.
You know, how dreams come to be in
anybody's life, but also the space
of dream is this, you know, the
relationship with the dreams
and the unconscious or some
experience that we have in life
that brings through, that's
kind of transformed, you know,
our conscious to dreams
good or bad experiences.
And also, the place of
literature as a place, you know,
if you think of literature and
the imagination as some space
like an empty page, a blank space,
the way you project your dreams.
>> Noemi Jaffe: Exactly,
it's perfect.
That's -- I really --
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: Another
question for you would be to think
about writing, the importance of
writing, like for your mother,
for example, writing was a
[inaudible] memoir, right?
After she left the camp,
but also the meaning.
I read that, you know, in her diary,
that she wrote for her daughters
to read, but also the meaning of her
writing from her, but also for you,
yourself, and your daughter.
Like three generations,
the meaning of writing.
Writing as, you know,
in psychoanalysis.
You know, when you have a
experience, a traumatic experience,
writing's always a good thing.
Like how to materialize the trauma.
You look at the trauma and like how
writing can be sort of a something
that can cure the trauma or
help you understand the trauma.
Would you say something about that?
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: Yes, that's
very interesting, because my mother,
after she wrote this diary,
which is 90 pages long,
she never wrote a single page in
her life after writing this diary.
She's not a writing kind of person,
and as you said, when I ask her,
why did you write this
diary if you don't write?
And she said, "For you to read it."
And she was 19 years
old at the time.
She couldn't even imagine
she would have children,
that she would meet my father,
and that she would come to Brazil.
But anyway, and so I think
that for her to write,
which is something she
wasn't used to doing.
Like when she wants
to write a letter,
we don't write letters anymore, but
when she wanted to write a letter,
because her brother was living
here in the United States,
she couldn't write more
than two lines like, "Hello.
I'm in good health.
So is my family.
Goodbye." So she always
asked me, "Please,
could you write a letter
for my brother?"
She couldn't write.
So I think that for her, it
actually was a kind of decision.
I interpret that now, a
kind of decision of hers
to extract her memory of what
had happened and leave it
in a diary, so she could forget it.
Because that's what she did.
So all of her memories
are in that diary.
She doesn't remember
anything different
from what's written in the diary.
You cannot make her
remember something casual.
It's all that's written
in the diary.
So I think it was a way for her to
deposit her memories somewhere else.
That's how I interpret it.
But for me, I think
I became a writer,
because since I was a really small
kid, like I was four years old,
I knew I wanted to become a writer.
That was the dream of my life.
Talking about dreams, right?
That was a dream of my life.
I invented books.
I read from books without
knowing how to read.
I opened books, and I
started reading them,
inventing what was written.
I invented languages.
I read my sisters' books.
They're much older than me, and I
read their books of psychoanalysis
when I was seven, eight years
old without understanding a word
of what I was reading, but I read.
So I think I became a writer
because of this diary.
Because I had to tell people what
my mother and my father told me
about what they had gone
through, and because I knew
that my mother had a diary,
which I didn't understand,
because I don't understand Serbian.
And that someday, I would
want to write about it.
So for me, writing is a
necessity, is a mission,
and it's also very therapeutic
for me to overcome the fact
that I'm the daughter of a survivor
and all the things
that this fact implies.
It implies a lot of guilt, a lot of
shame, and after writing this book,
which was like the
mission of my life,
I think now I can start
writing about other things.
And it was very therapeutic
to me, too.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: And how
long have you been, you know,
how long has this book
been like as a project?
Another question for you would
be like when did you hear
about your mother's diary?
>> Noemi Jaffe: Since I was a kid.
She never hid it from us.
So when I was four, I knew about
the existence of this diary.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: But
you couldn't read it, right?
>> Noemi Jaffe: I couldn't
read it, but everything
that she told us is exactly the
same that was written in the diary.
So when we finally translated,
we have this book translated,
the diary translated into
Portuguese, which was in the 90s,
I was more than 30
years old already.
What we read were exactly
the same facts
that she told us all our lives.
So I always knew about it.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: And
another question would be
like because your mother's diary
is in first-person point of view,
and your narrative
is in third-person --
>> Noemi Jaffe: Third person.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
Like the daughter.
Could you tell a little
bit about that, please?
>> Noemi Jaffe: That was a very
important decision that I made,
because when I started writing my
part of the book, I was writing it
in the first person, because it's
about the story of my mother,
about my life, my sisters'
lives, my opinions.
But I wasn't feeling
comfortable with it,
because the book wasn't about me.
I already felt that I was
stealing my mother's memories,
and not only was I stealing,
I was also talking about me.
I didn't feel the right to
do it in the first person,
and I also didn't want
to be so truthful.
I wanted to be able to fictionalize
little, and then I tried.
I made an experiment to
write it in third person,
and as soon as I began,
I felt so much more free.
When I started writing in the
third person, I could invent more.
I could acquire a little
more distance towards myself.
I felt I wasn't in the
center of everything.
I wanted my mother to be the center.
I wanted the issues to be the
center of attention and not me.
And yeah, that's the reason.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
That's very interesting,
because the book has these three
parts, and one is the diary,
and there is the second part,
it's Noemi's narrative part
and her granddaughter, or her
daughter also writing at the end
about her experience being the
grandchild of the survivor.
So it's very interesting to
see these three elements.
And I think, you know,
think about memories.
Because I think also is the question
of how much can we grasp
in terms of memory?
You know, what's real?
Because the written text has
a tendency to fix things.
We think this is what
really happened.
You know, especially for someone
that writes, but there's a lot
of questions like in testimonial
literature, in terms of our own
like subjectivity in writing
that's very interesting to see.
Your book is a project, like
trying to understand what happened.
Three different perspectives
of the same fact,
of the same history event.
>> Noemi Jaffe: Yes, and we all
have very different perspectives
about what happened.
Like my mother tells me sometimes,
"Noemi, you suffer more than I did."
Because she doesn't
suffer anymore, right?
She accepts the fact
that she suffered,
and that her suffering
ended, and I'm the opposite.
I'm always cultivating suffering.
I'm always, interpreting
thinking and, you know,
more intellectualizing
and thinking about things.
What does it mean to survive?
What does it mean to forget?
What does it mean to remember?
And she tells me, "Don't
exaggerate so much.
You're so dramatic.
Why do you make things
so complicated?"
You know, for her a fact is a
fact, but she lived the fact.
I didn't. So what is left
for me is thinking, right?
This stupid thing that
we do, and my daughter,
she's a little more distant.
A little more?
No, she's a lot more distant, right?
Because she's not the daughter of
someone who went through the war,
and so she doesn't feel this
guilt that I feel or this rage,
because my mother doesn't
feel anger.
She forbid herself to
feel any kind of anger,
not even towards the Nazis.
And I feel a lot of anger.
I want to go back to the
past and kill the men
who made my mother carry the
stone on top of her head, right?
So I feel guilt.
I feel rage, and my daughter,
she doesn't feel any
kind of guilt, right?
She's free to live her life.
She doesn't have any
relationship with the war.
She wants to fight for
other causes, right?
She's a very strong feminist,
like all the girls nowadays,
thank God, are feminists.
So she's a strong feminist.
She fights for other causes in
Brazil, and so her relationship
with her grandmother's
life is different,
but it's also very
interesting, right?
Her relation to Judaism
is also different.
So the book contains
these three perspectives.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: Thank you.
I think I should let the
audience ask some questions,
if you have more questions,
you know, in case we need.
But I think if anybody has a
question you could ask Noemi.
Talia?
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
I talked to you
about this before how [inaudible],
but I have never seen a book
but in three voices with a
three generation [inaudible],
and I was wondering how
you came to that decision.
Well, diary I guess [inaudible].
>> Noemi Jaffe: Right.
It's interesting, because
my daughter,
when I was writing
the book, she was 21.
Now she's 28, but she was studying
languages at the University
of San Paulo, and she also
wanted to be a writer.
She was a writer already, and
then, so one day, I asked her,
would you like to write
the book with us?
She said, yes, why not?
And then we went to Auschwitz,
I asked her to come with me,
and she did, and when we entered
Auschwitz, I said let's try to find,
here in Auschwitz, things
that tourists don't find.
Let's try to see the details about,
the different things
about Auschwitz.
And so I started walking
through the museums in the rooms
and the barracks and the
windows full of shoes and hair
and suitcases looking at the
small things like the names
on the suitcases and the
streets, the addresses,
and the braids in the hair.
Like so there are three windows
full of hair to the top, right?
The hair that was taken
from people's heads.
So I was looking at the braids
in the hair, and when we went
to the museums, I was writing
down the names of the survivors.
And then my daughter started
looking at me in this strange way,
and she was getting mad and
mad and mad, until she said,
"Why are looking at different
things here in Auschwitz?
There's nothing different
to look at!
You know, there's no
detail to look at.
You shouldn't look at the braids.
You shouldn't look at the names.
Let's get out of here.
I don't want to be part
of this book anymore!
What did you bring me here?"
She was really mad at me,
at the way I was trying
to find poetry in Auschwitz.
So she decided not to
participate in the book.
So we have this big
discussion in Poland.
We were fighting in Poland, and then
after, you know, we discussed a lot,
and when we back to Brazil,
she said, "No, all right.
All have a part in the book,
but only a very small part.
The book is yours."
And I agreed with her.
And that saw how it came
about, these three parts.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Yes, she's 90 years old, and she's
very -- she's fine, she's healthy.
>> Did she read the book?
>> Noemi Jaffe: Yes, many times.
Many times.
She really likes it.
Very happy with it.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
No, she talks about it all
the time with no problem.
No problem.
Talking about it, and talking
about everything that it contains.
She talks about it as if it
hadn't happened with her.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Yes, yes. She even asks herself,
how was I able to endure it?
She doesn't understand how she
was able to endure pain, cold,
starvation, like every time
she feels hungry, she says,
"I'm not feeling very well
because I'm a little hungry.
How could I endure feeling
hunger for a whole year?"
The same when she feels cold, right?
Is she feels a little cold,
she looks for a sweater,
and so she asks herself,
how could I endure it?
She even laughs about it.
She doesn't understand.
So she doesn't have any
problems telling us.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Yeah, I think my mother's attitude
is the healthiest possible attitude
towards a trauma, right?
Because there are people
who like to live in the past
and who suffer all of their lives.
I mean, I can't blame them,
because if you go through something
like this, you can't blame
a person in any way, right?
If the person wants to
remember, let him remember.
forget, let him forget.
Everything is acceptable and right.
But I think the way my
mother did is the best.
Right? Because my mother
is a happy person.
She's a very generous,
optimistic, happy person.
Whenever I feel sad, she's there
to, you know, encourage me,
and she's encouraging everyone.
She's teaching people how to
endure things all the time.
So I think it's the best
way to go through problems.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
I hope so.
So much.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
Just following
up on your comment to her question.
I remember like reading your book.
There is so much about dignity and
endurance and also destiny of fate,
and your mother's acceptance
of death.
Something that you mentioned like
the present, like all the survivors
in the camp expecting, you know,
like death was to be expected.
Her perception of death is
what kept her alive, I guess.
>> Noemi Jaffe: Yeah,
she's not afraid of death.
She's not afraid of anything.
I think after you go
through the things she did,
you don't feel afraid of things.
And she always taught us, her
daughters, not to be afraid.
The three of us were all
very, we're very -- fighters.
Is that what you say?
I don't know.
We're fighters, but not very
fearful people, the three of us.
But she's more.
She's braver than us.
And she's not afraid of anything.
Like, is 90 years old now.
She says to us, "I'm
not afraid of dying.
I may not be -- not
wake up tomorrow.
That's all right."
We're more afraid of
her death and she is.
She's not afraid of anything.
She's only afraid of sickness.
Not of her sickness, of ours,
and her grandchildren, right?
And so that's what she's afraid of.
Which is totally understandable,
right?
And also, in the book,
there are many experiences
that she talks about.
Like when she was asked
by her cousins to confess
that she had stolen butter from the
kitchen, and she hadn't done it.
So she says, all right, I'll do
it, because her cousins were afraid
of confessing, and she wasn't.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: And that's
[inaudible] the punishment.
Because it's like a key
in the story [inaudible].
>> Noemi Jaffe: Yes, it's
the axis of the book.
I think it's the --
[ Inaudible Speech ]
No, it really helped me.
Not immediately, but like, now,
many years after I wrote
the book -- not many years.
Three years, four years after I
wrote the book, as I told you,
I'm ready to write
about other things,
because I was always thinking
about being Jewish and surviving
and remembering or
forgetting, and now I'm ready
to write about other things.
I think it's been very,
very important for my life
to have written this book, in order
to overcome many problems that I had
and that I feel like I used
to have any, many nightmares.
I don't anymore.
Yeah, not having good dreams.
So I think I managed to
get rid of the nightmares.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Yes, but as I was telling
him about the stone.
So this is a very central
thing in the book,
and the story of my
mother's life and in my life,
because my mother spent all her
time in the concentration camp
with her cousins, three cousins.
They were sisters.
And they were all working
in the kitchen.
I think that's the main
reason why my mother survived,
because she managed to
work in the kitchen,
in the kitchen they
had more access to food
like potato peels and
things like that.
And they used to steal butter to
give it to people who were sick,
and one day, the officer realized
that some butter had been stolen,
and one of the cousins had stolen
the butter, but they were afraid
of confessing, because
they were three sisters,
and they knew that
if they confessed,
the officer might send
them to death.
And so my mother was somewhere else,
and when she arrived in the kitchen,
they asked my mother to
confess that she had done it,
and she said all right, I'll do it.
And she went to the officer and
she said, "I stole the butter."
And the officer said,
"Are you kidding?
You're coming to me to confess you
stole something from the kitchen?"
Yes. So she was supposed to be sent
to death, but then she begged not
to die, so the officer, I
don't know for what reason,
decided only to punish her
more lightly and asked her
to carry a stone on top
of her head for a couple
of hours kneeling on gravel.
Yes. And she couldn't cry, and
she couldn't the stone fall,
and when these hours passed, the
officer came and said, "All right,
now get up and go to work."
And she couldn't even stand.
Her knee is injured until
this day, and she told us,
she never spared us from the story.
When we were kids, she told us
this story, so we always knew,
we the sisters, we always knew
what my mother had gone through,
but to me, this fact, to know that
my mother had gone through this,
it was like determinant in my life.
It wasn't a simple thing.
And so I wrote two chapters
about this fact in the book,
and I think the whole book
circles around this fact, my life.
>> What was the name of
the concentration camp?
>> Noemi Jaffe: Auschwitz.
>> Auschwitz?
>> Noemi Jaffe: Yes.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
Any other questions?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> And then another thing I
was hearing was resilience.
You know, it seems there are more
resilient or not, but you know,
that whole topic of
resilience, I'm sure [inaudible].
>> Noemi Jaffe: Okay, thank
you for the questions.
First of all, in terms of what is
happening in the world right now,
I think the worst problem
that is happening
in the world right now is
the problem of the refugees.
And so I was reading a book now
in the United States written
by a Mexican writer
called [Portuguese name],
a very nice writer.
You know her?
And so she was -- she writes
about the children from Guatemala,
Puerto Rico, Mexico, who are
coming to the United States alone,
all by themselves, orphans
from these countries.
They're being persecuted by
gangs in their countries.
They're being killed and
raped in their countries,
and they come to the United
States followed by a coyote.
And they get here, and they
cannot enter the country, right?
The country won't let them in,
but the country is responsible
for what's happening to them.
I'm sorry to say that here
in the Library of Congress,
but the country's responsible
for what's happening to them,
because the United States
supported the war in their countries
against them, and they
won't let them in.
They need to find a lawyer
as soon as they get here,
and they need to have
reasons that proves
to get inside the United States.
So that's just one example
of what's happening.
Right? Children wanting to get
into a country that is responsible
for what's happening to them, but
the country won't let them in.
And so [Portuguese name]
decided to do something for it.
So she's a translator
for these kids.
In Chechnya, there are
concentration camps for homosexuals.
In Syria, right, people are being
killed like animals, and in Europe,
people won't be let in, right?
And it's the same thing.
Europe is also responsible
for what's happening in Asia,
and I think these are some of the
problems that are happening today,
and that many people shut their
eyes toward these problems.
And in Brazil, I can't even start
telling you all the problems
we have.
And about resilience, I attribute
my mother's resilience first
to the fact that she
believes in destiny.
I think that makes
things easier for people.
I don't believe in destiny at all.
That makes me a little less
resilient than my mother.
I believe more in our choices and
people's choices to do things.
Not that things are prewritten
and that we only obey,
we follow something
that is not up to us.
I think that makes things
easier for people, right?
She thinks is that supposed
to happen, it will happen.
If not, it won't.
And also, because of
what Vivaldo was saying
about her, the maintenance.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: Maintenance.
>> Noemi Jaffe: Maintenance
of her sense of dignity.
You know? Like in the war, she would
sleep naked in order not to get lice
in her clothes, and she always
carried a spoon with her,
or she would make a needle out of
straw in order to sew a blanket
for herself, and like
she's 90 years old now,
but she's always hanging
her close on a hanger
and her shoes are always,
you know, very neatly placed,
one beside the other,
and everything's so neat
in her bedroom and her linen.
You know, she's always
taking care of herself
and using lipstick and makeup.
She's always looking pretty.
I think that makes a
person resilient, right?
She values her sense of being.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: Being.
>> Noemi Jaffe: Being, exactly.
>> My question is about
language and culture.
So you talked about her
understanding Portuguese
and how she speaks to this
day not quite properly,
but she always speak Portuguese?
Did she bring any of her Serbian
with her, and in community,
is she strongly identified
with the Jewish community,
or has she assimilated, and how
important is Judaism to her now?
>> Noemi Jaffe: Okay, good.
Yes, when my father was alive,
they would speak Serbian
between themselves.
But none of us sisters
speak Serbian.
Only my older sister, used
to, because when they came,
they didn't speak Portuguese.
So they spoke Serbian all the time,
and she spoke a little Serbian.
And my grandmother, who came with
my father, also spoke German.
So my sister also speaks
a little German.
Otherwise, they spoke Portuguese.
And so after my father died, my
father died 21 years ago already,
and so she only spoke Portuguese,
and now she forgot
part of her Serbian.
She also spoke a lot of Hungarian.
She spoke Hungarian very
well, because in the city
where she was born, they spoke
both Hungarian and Serbian.
So she understands at little
Hungarian, but she has to talk to,
and so she only speaks
Portuguese with us.
And no, she gives great
value to Judaism.
She's not religious at all but
she's not assimilated either.
We keep the main celebrations,
Passover, Hashanah, Yom Kippur,
we always celebrate in her house.
She still cooks the main
dishes for these celebrations.
She goes to the synagogue only
in the most important holidays
of the year, but she
likes being Jewish.
None of us -- oh, no, my
middle sister lives in Israel,
but my older sister and
myself, we never married Jews.
And grandchildren didn't marry
Jews either, but she doesn't care.
It's okay with her.
But she gives a lot of
importance to being Jewish.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
I have -- okay.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Noemi Jaffe: My grandmother.
My mother.
>> Your mother.
So your mother [inaudible].
>> Noemi Jaffe: She
wrote in Serbian.
>> Have any of her writings
been circulated in Serbia,
which has its own recent
[inaudible],
and how was it received?
>> Noemi Jaffe: I'm
sorry, I didn't understand.
>> Have your mother's writings,
anything about this time,
been circulated in
Serbian in Serbia?
>> Noemi Jaffe: No.
No.
>> Has she had any conversations
with Serbia about any of this?
>> Noemi Jaffe: No.
No, because she hasn't been
speaking in Serbian for many years,
20 years, since my father died.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
But did they --
there was a TV recording or
interview with -- nothing?
>> Noemi Jaffe: In Brazil,
there was, but not in Serbia.
I wish they translated it into
Serbian or into Swedish, also,
because she spent six months in
Sweden when she was liberated,
but so far it hasn't
been translated.
Only into English.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: So
where is the diary now?
>> Noemi Jaffe: The diary
now, it was deposited
in the Holocaust Museum
in Jerusalem, right?
Because we thought that
was the place for it.
And so my sister took it
there and gave it to them.
So we're very happy that it's
there now, along with its mates.
>> How long was she in
the concentration camp?
>> Noemi Jaffe: Eleven months.
From April 1944 to March 1945.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: That may
be our last question for you,
but you know, it's you
and your three sisters.
My question is about the
place of your father.
The place in your writing.
>> Noemi Jaffe: Yes, yes, well,
there's a big, huge place for him,
and I hope to someday write
a book about his story.
It's totally different from my
mother's story, and he is also part
of the diary, because when
my mother gave him the --
when my mother went back to
Serbia after the war to see if any
of her relatives had
survived, he met my father,
and my father immediately fell
in love with her, and she didn't.
[ Laughter ]
She wanted to come to the United
States because her brother was here.
He had joined the American army.
So she went Hungary and left her
diary with my father as a token
of her friendship, and my father
filled the diary with love letters
to her, and these love
letters, they're like, you know,
you are in love letters,
so romantic.
And so my father went
after her to Hungary,
because he had a large family
in Brazil, and he told her
to marry him, only bureaucratically,
so she would go to Brazil with him,
and then in Brazil,
she would get documents
to come to the United States.
And so they went to Brazil.
The trip took a long time,
and in the middle of the way,
something happened and -- I
guess he knew what was going
to happen, right?
And when they arrived in Brazil,
they married again, and they stayed.
She got pregnant and everything.
But his story's totally
different than hers.
He stayed in a small concentration
camp, not an extermination camp,
but a labor camp, and
this camp disappeared.
It was in Austria.
And he had a totally
different attitude from hers.
He was the kind who was
cultivating suffering.
And so maybe someday I'll
write about his story.
But I didn't want to mix his story
and her story in the same book.
This is a book of women.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: Thank you.
I think there is an
image in your book,
and I think you also gave
an exemplary of your mother
like sewing, making needle
to sew her own clothes.
But also, for a writer,
it's also the same idea.
The style in writing.
>> Noemi Jaffe: Exactly.
The word text comes from sewing, and
a book, the books are sewn, right?
And so...
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
Any more questions?
I have like many questions, but
I don't think we have much time.
I'm sure your book has been
well received in Brazil and also
to the contemporary, present
literature is so diverse, I think,
also, you know, I think Georgette
was mentioning, the Jewish,
you know, event happening
here, but also in Brazil
after the publication, I mean,
we have a Jewish tradition,
but I think especially
after the publication
of the [inaudible] there's a
lot going on in the Jewish --
being Jewish being
Brazilian, I think it's --
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Would you read for us?
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
Oh, of course.
>> Noemi Jaffe: Yeah, sure.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez: Would
you mind reading [inaudible]?
>> Noemi Jaffe: No.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
To make sure [inaudible].
>> Noemi Jaffe: I could read it
in Portuguese and then in English.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez: You read
it so beautifully this morning,
but I think it's [inaudible].
>> Vivaldo dos Santos:
You should have told me.
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: If
it's not too challenging.
[ Reading in Portuguese ]
>> Vivaldo dos Santos: The stone
of fact is larger than the stone
of history, than the
stone if symbol.
But those who have not experienced
the stone itself and who are sons
and daughters of the
fact can only think of it
as an indirect occurrence
which carries a symbolic force.
Stone. [inaudible] stone,
Margaretta stone, square stone,
rectangular stone, cement
stone, sandstone, pointy stones,
smooth stones, heavy stone, dense
stone, large stone, practical stone,
brittle stone, gray stone, opaque
stone, real stone, unreal stone,
painful stone, still stone,
movable stone, difficult stone,
impassable stone, hard stone, hearty
stone, lost stone, equal stone,
common stone, unique stone, idiotic
stone, innocent stone, sticky stone,
distant stone, actual stone, crusty
stone, loose stone, any stone,
mineral stone, ornamental stone,
stony stone, polished stone,
touchstone, philosopher's
stone, fundamental stone,
chipped stone, sleek stone.
The stone in your shoe, precious
stone, semi-precious stone,
rolling stone, kidney stone,
keystone, crumbling stone,
sharpening stone, dry stone,
pre-stone, post-stone,
to throw the first stone, to
squeeze blood from a stone,
to be hard as stone, to
never have seen the stone,
to picture the stone, to be in
her place holding the stone.
Being the child of a survivor
mean stealing the temptation
in some distant and
inhospitable part of your memory,
to have been in the
survivor's place.
To not have let her live through
all that she lived through,
to travel to the past and stop him.
To kill the guard who
ordered her punishment.
To pierce through time and
through the [inaudible] regulations
and save her.
A mother who has suffered
is a failure of history,
a twist of reversal which leads
her children into the minute guilt
and absence and a dream or
a nightmare that they carry
with them throughout the day, and
which impedes and stimulates life.
The desire to save one's
mother is also a desire
to eradicate her suffering from
our memories so that she, herself,
can be freed of it, so that
she can live without the stone.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.